JOEL: I just wanted to
introduce you to Brad.
He's a friend of a former
Google manager of mine,
and we connected.
Brad has worked in
the technology space,
but has a background in
the liberal arts space,
so got roped in,
became a coder, and has
been doing all sorts of
great projects since then.
He's coming back to his roots
in terms of this liberal arts
and wrote this book.
It has a technology slant in
it, so really applicable to us.
Something I read recently
of Brad's, he did this Op Ed
in "New York Times" about
how technology and art
and the humanities really
need to go together
for successful outcomes.
I think, at Google,
we talk about how
diversity is important.
And we think of
diversity in terms
of male/female,
different backgrounds.
But certainly, one of the
kind of diverse backgrounds
we can think about at
Google is this idea
of not just I grew up,
learned a lot of math,
started, got CS degree
and came to Google.
But maybe there's different
ways people can get to Google
and provide good computer
science without necessarily
that CS degree.
And hopefully, we can ask Brad
some questions about that.
So without further ado, I'd like
to give the time over to Brad.
J. BRADFORD HIPPS: Thank you.
Thanks, Joel.
Thank you all for coming.
Thanks for your patience.
So I'm going to--
the good news is I
won't be reading from an Op Ed.
I'm going to be reading
straight fiction.
So you can close your eyes,
hopefully get somewhat absorbed
in the story.
As Joel said, I--
one of the, I guess,
animating ideas for
me for this book,
which is called
"The Adventurist"--
I guess I'm supposed to,
should I hold it up and plug it
properly-- is the fact that,
in a lot of the reading I had
done, I did not see much in
literature that really made
much in the way of attempting to
depict the work world that many
of us certainly in this room,
but collectively as a country
inhabit.
I think, by and
large, the work world
is usually depicted satirically,
which is funny and fun.
But it's obviously also
a very flattening lens.
So one of the things
that interested me, not
the only thing with
the novel, but one
of things that
interested me was,
what would it be
like if you attempted
to write a book that actually
took the work world seriously?
Not in the sense that you didn't
find things to gently poke fun
at, but that you actually
recognize the fact
that a lot of us come to work
in offices like these-- actually
not usually this good-- but
in offices similar to these.
And we find a range
of experiences.
We find experiences that
are both affirmative.
We're applauded for our
innovation and our work.
And we also find
conflict and rivalry.
We may find crushes.
I think the full
range of human emotion
does occur inside the work
world, inside these offices,
even though that's
not typically,
at least in popular culture
terms, the way it's reflected.
So that, as I said, that
was an animating idea.
When I was thinking
last night about what
to read out of the book here,
I was wrestling a little bit.
And I wound up gravitating
toward some of the earlier
scenes where the work
environment is being anchored.
And I thought to myself,
that's a great idea.
And then when I
showed up, I'm like,
these folks have stepped
out of the work environment
to have a break.
And now I'm going to read
something that may thrust them
right back into it.
But let's give it a shot.
I'm not going to read for
too long, 10-15 minutes.
And then if there are
questions about the book
or, as Joel said, anything
else you want to talk about,
we can do that.
And I'm also happy to inscribe
books if folks are interested.
I've taken a slight liberty.
I'm going to concatenate
two scenes here.
So the way I'll read it
is not precisely the way
it flows in the book.
But that's not really
material to you.
So this is "The Adventurist."
There are three
characters you care about.
The narrator's name is Henry.
The person that's
going to show up
the most in the scene with
him is a guy named Barry.
Barry heads up sales.
Henry, the narrator,
heads up engineering.
They work for a company called
Cyber, which, as you see,
is having some struggles.
And the only other
name, I think,
that isn't introduced here is
a guy by the name of Keith.
And he's the general manager.
They work for Keith.
So Henry, narrator, Barry,
head of sales, Keith, the boss.
"The Monday management meeting.
There are five of the us,
department heads each,
Sales, Marketing, Engineering,
Operations, Finance.
There's also Keith.
We report to him.
It is his meeting.
I'm aware that nothing
conjures the tedium of business
so much as a weekly meeting.
And it is true we deliver our
reports in the most nickel
plated of monotones.
The worst you can do
here is to insist.
We are authoritative by
our very bloodlessness.
Yet the truth is I
crave these sessions.
Here, commercial necessities
are turned to concrete actions
with measurements and
owners and due dates,
and there is no
Paul to speak of.
Barry is last to present.
He concludes his report
by saying he remains
pleased with the pipeline.
Keith flips the few pages of the
Sales report with a sour look.
'You're pleased with the
pipeline,' he says finally.
The pipeline is a list of
sales prospects and dollar
values along with the percentage
chance of our winning the deal.
'Well, I am pleased you're
pleased.' Barry shakes his head
and gives the table
a vaudevillian look.
'I know I said this
for a couple weeks.
But if some of these don't
hit next week.' Some chuckle
supportively.
Keith does not.
'Then what?'
'Sorry?'
'If some of these don't
hit next week, then what?'
'Well, then I should look
for a new head of sales.
Ha!
Ah, no.'
Keith waits, an ear cocked
in Barry's direction.
In these meetings,
the role of listener
also carries with it certain
affectations, eyes narrowed,
legs crossed, pen to
lips, the occasional nod
or frown, the corporate
world's skeptical punctuation.
None of which applies to Keith.
Keith doesn't go
for affectation.
'I feel excellent
about these Keith.
Maybe not the ones listed
at 20% probability.
But these 60 and
above ones, oh boy.'
'That's two, two
opportunities at 60%.
What's your revenue target?'
'Right at 15 for the quarter.'
'4, $4 million.
What's the total value of these
two, assuming we get them,
which I most certainly am not?'
'One million.'
'One million?
It's not even that much,
friend, not according to this.
You've got 750 here.
$500,000 for Marketel,
250 for Delta.
Any deal north of
a million is still
sitting in sub 20 probability,
which means we have what?
Two three quarters of coaxing
ahead of us for any of those,
best case.'
Barry's phone buzzes
in its holster.
He consults it
seriously, hopefully.
'OK,' Keith says, 'All right.
Let's take these one at a time.
Focus on the birds in hand.
Marketel, it's the biggest
of the 60% probabilities .
You see them this week?'
'Thursday,' Barry affirms.
'Talk to us about the strategy.'
Having pressed him,
Keith will back off.
It is important that Barry
leave on a note of confidence.
Buyers can smell
panic on a salesman.
'Well, I've got a
new contact there.
My old guy was bumped.'
'Uh-oh,' says Keith, but
not without sympathy.
'No, it might could
work in our favor.
The G2 I have on this new guy
is that he's pretty respected.
He could probably
move things quick.'
'What do we know about him?'
'Not a ton.
He's from the inside.
I know that.
I don't have to re-educate
him on who we are.'
'Good.
No lost ground.
He's from inside the company?
What group?'
'Engineering, I think.
90% sure.'
'A tech guy?
OK.
Take Henry with you.'
Barry nods energetically
as though he were
about to propose just this.
But what he says is, 'Yes,
although I'm thinking on this
one, since I haven't met this
guy myself yet, I fly solo,
build the relationship, then
bring in a heavy hitter like
Henry.' He means he doesn't
want to share credit if the deal
closes.
I don't blame him.
It's not my desire to
go along in any case.
Business travel no
longer suits me.
An ominous glow comes
into Keith's face.
Through sheer
professional will, he
appears to consider
Barry's plan.
Then he says, 'No.
No time.
We need to hit this guy with
everything we've got in this
week.'
'Agree 100%.
My only thing is I don't want
to scare the guy off, you know?
He hasn't even met me.
And all of a sudden, I'm up
there with an army of folks.'
'Not an army.
One other person, our director
of engineering, which shows
how much we value his time.
We're sparing two
of our directors.'
'Yup.
The only other thing,
because of our situation,
Barry,' Keith interrupts,
his temper slipping again.
'Our situation is this.
It's January 12th.
We have about 10 weeks to get to
4 million.' He catches himself,
nods, addresses the table.
'And we'll do it.
No question.
But we don't have a lot of room.
Marketel is key.
Barry's done a great
job priming them.'
Here, Barry studies
his lap modestly.
'And the deals worth
half a million,
so we would be a
good ways along.
And I think we'll
nail it,' Barry adds,
though he's distracted again by
his phone and is tapping away
even as he says this.
This is too much.
Keith sets a careful
hand on the table.
'Barry, next week, I want
to hear what you know,
what you have made happen, not
what you fucking think.' He
slapped shut his portfolio
and is first out of the room.
There is a brief, even
apologetic clearing of throats.
People rise and fall out.
Berry touches a
hand to my sleeve.
He shuts the door
behind the last person,
ducking his head to scan
the terrain for the room's
low portal windows.
Satisfied the hall is free
of spies, he faces me.
'That guy.'
'Keith.'
'Keith, yes.
I mean sometimes he
gets to me, you know?'
'He'll catch twice as much hell
when he delivers his report,'
'Oh, I know.
I know,' Barry replies quickly.
He is silent for a moment,
nodding his agreement
while pacing a tight circle.
He has tucked his hands in
the pockets of his trousers
so that the thumbs
remain exposed.
It is an unnatural stance.
He has to stiffen at
the elbows to hold it.
A lawyer, delivering impassioned
closing to skeptical jury.
The poor bastard.
'Might have waited to
make his point though.'
'Exactly.
That's exactly it.
I'm not saying he's wrong.
I'm on the hook here.
No two ways about it.
But in front of everyone else?
That's what gets me.
That's all I'm saying.
And then you get dragged along,
which I'm sorry about that.' He
wags his head and sighs.
'It just makes you wonder,
you know, this place,
whether it's all worth it.'
Ah.
But already he is recovering.
I know that sigh.
In it is captured the
entire American romance
of moving forward, moving on.
A job well done or not well
done or not done at all.
Never mind.
Turn the page, a blank
sheet, a fresh start.
And this time, yes, Barry
is a true wax and waner.
Whatever his dejection is now,
it will not last the week.
Sunday morning will come again.
The sales call is a
disaster from top to bottom.
For starters, there
is the weather.
A warm front has heaved
north from the Gulf
and rolled the landscape under
fathoms of invection fog."
Marketel, the customer
they are going to visit,
is in Minneapolis.
And they're based in the South.
"In the gloom, we
miss an exit and carry
on for a full 20 minutes
before realizing our mistake.
When finally we arrive
at the Marketel offices,
Barry is in a state.
He leaps from the
rental car and is
nearly across the
parking lot before
remembering his portfolio.
I wait by the entrance.
The building is part of a
newly tilled office park,
near the Mall of America.
A long two-story brick
affair, its architecture
is as square and
utilitarian as boxcars.
There is little to inspire
in these office parks,
yet the companies
they house are usually
as stolid and
profitable as banks.
Sponges for every bit of
available local talent
and run by top graduates of the
state's best public university.
Some of the most
frank, rooted people
I've met, people who've
never in their lives
coveted a more epic
context go gladly
to work each day in these
anonymous pill boxes.
I envy them.
Barry returns with
portfolio he is wired even
by his own electric standard.
'Let's hit it.'
Our contact is waiting
at the security desk.
His wide face burns
with cheeriness.
'You're the Cyber guys?'
He extends a hand.
'Mike Catrell.
I'm the new sheriff, I guess.'
Barry clasps his arm and
snaps it like a well pump.
'Glad to put a face to the name.
This is my associate, Henry.
He directs our
engineering group.
We brought all the big guns.'
Mike is perhaps 40.
He carries a sort of
pregnant girth in his belt,
slung over a pair of
creaseless trousers.
His loafers are
stained with road salt.
I'm tempted to read in this mild
sloppiness, a genial spirit.
But there is a beady-eyedness
that puts me on my guard.
'Mike, I'm sorry about
the time,' Barry says,
'The usual travel
hiccups, I'm afraid.'
Our host lets drop my hand and
turns to face Barry directly.
His movements are oddly sedate.
'Hard stop at 11.'
'Oh, I thought-- I could've
sworn we booked through lunch.'
'11,' his tone is
mild, even benevolent,
'You guys were any later,
I would've canceled.'
We follow Mike to a conference
room on the second floor.
It is a narrow
hall like chamber,
featureless but for a
bank of slatted windows.
The carpet is gray.
An immense oval table
commands the floor.
This is a room built
to vet vendors, I know.
Solemnity is its point.
But someone has made a mistake.
The screws have been
turned a little too tight.
With its mass slab
table and grim colors,
its narrow dimensions
and hyperbaric air,
the seriousness of
the room is in danger
of turning over on itself.
It is very nearly hilarious.
Four other men are
clustered at one end.
Each is introduced
somberly as one kind
of specialist or another.
When we are acquainted and
seated, Mike nods to Barry.
Barry hops from
his seat to begin.
'My apologies all
around for the delay.
I'll get straight in because
I know our time is limited.
Can we skip all the song and
dance on Cyber's background
and standing as a company?
Everyone's nodding yes.
All right.
So we'll start with
the technical portion,
my colleague Henry's portion.
We can circle back for any
more general questions.
So I'll just dim the lights.
And the switch is where?
Here.
Yes.
Henry?'
It is a part of the job, a day
to help sales, make pitches
of a certain type, often to
large, cynical prospects who
want to see and hear from
the person whose team will
make sure the software behaves.
And once the oddness of arrival
and introduction has passed,
I find it's a job I can do.
I like to explain
our technologies.
Even the idioms of our
science appeal to me,
wedding cakes, fish
bones, bit rot.
And usually, among
other engineers,
I'll encounter a shared
interest, an appreciation
at the least, for the
decisions we've made,
for the strategies we've
studied and rejected,
and the reasons for
their dismissal.
Only today, what
I find is silence.
Mike studies the table.
The others regard my slides
with the wax and look
of actors feigning death.
I can see nothing
to do but press on.
Barry, however, is itchy.
After several slides, he
begins to hear interjections
in every cleared throat.
'Mark, you had a question?'
Our host looks up
from the table.
There is a moment's confusion.
He folds his arms
and squints at Barry.
'Are you speaking to me?'
'Yes.'
'Mike.'
'Mike.
Forgive me.
You had a question?'
'No.'
"i thought you
looked like you did.'
'You'll know if I
have a question.'
'Of course.'
The best sales pitch
I ever heard about was
made by a cyber competitor.
It was told to me by
the salesman himself
whom I met one evening at
a conference in Washington.
He told me about
a sale he had once
made to the Central
Intelligence Agency,
as jaded and bored an audience
as you could ever hope to find.
There is nothing, but
nothing a mere salesman
could tell the CIA
about security.
But it became suddenly
inclined to buy
when it was revealed that the
salesman's analyst, pounding
away on a keyboard at
the back of the room,
had contrived to deface the
agency website in the time it
took to pass around the coffee.
But here there are only
mannequin faces in the room.
The minutes drip.
When I'm finished, Barry
stands and raises the lights.
He smacks his hands together,
rubbing them and making
a slight bow to our host.
Mike remains as he has
throughout, absorbed
by the area of the
table in front of him.
'So Mark,' Barry prompts,
'Now, what are your questions?'
We are lost.
This emphasis on
name is meant to show
he's taken special
care to get it right,
except because he has
fumbled the name again,
the effect is opposite.
It seems he's making some
bizarre point of defiance.
Mike says nothing.
He stares at the table,
his arms crossed heavily
over belly, a forelock of
hair drops onto his eyebrow.
He smooths it into place with
his ring and pinky fingers.
The gesture is ominously
dainty, bottled.
Barry sees his mistake.
'Mike.
Mike!
What is wrong with me today?'
Our host picks microscopic
lint from his trousers.
'I don't know.
What is wrong with you today?'
The question is posed
offhandedly, almost kindly.
It is possible to
imagine he's as
curious in the answer as Barry.
'It's the cold,' Berry pries,
'Us southerners don't do well
in the snow.
Our brains freeze.'
Mike leaps from his chair
and thrusts out a hand.
'I want to thank you.' He is
grinning, shaking Barry's arm.
'A revealing presentation.
Guys, am I wrong?'
His team swaps private glances.
Mike calls to one of them.
'Tom, what was your
favorite part.'
Silence.
Mike lears at the group.
His eyes pop with
goodwill of expectancy.
One of the men
clears his throat.
'Tim, I think you mean.'
'Tim.
Yes,' he throws back his head
in marvel. 'How stupid of me!
Goddamn brainless!
You're critical to
our business here,
so to not get your name
right, I feel like a turd.'
Tim smiles uncomfortably.
Mike paces to the window.
There he stands nodding,
tapping his lip.
'I wouldn't be
surprised, Tim, if you
wanted to walk right out of
here, never talk to me again.
Wouldn't blame you a bit.
Quality in everything,
that's what we preach.
So the least you'd expect
is that I could remember
your name, no?'
'Yes, absolutely right.'
He turns to Barry whose face
has gone bland and waxy.
'Safe travels, friend.'
In the stairwell, Barry pulls
off his spectacles and digs
at his eyes with
thumb and forefinger.
'Barry, the man is certifiable.
Forget it.'
'No,' Barry replaces his frames,
blinking at me through glass,
'We don't talk about
customers that way.'
This is how he will have it.
His dignity will be
restored by lesson giving.
As engineer, I misunderstand
the dynamics of selling.
It falls to him to show
how the licking just
received is, in fact,
a small sacrifice
for fealty to the high
cause of customer service.
It's no small alchemy to
turn a humiliating episode
into a business lesson with
Barry as a master of subtleties
and my poor nuts and
bolts brain has missed.
Having been condescended
to, Barry would condescend.
And if I were a bigger person,
I might allow him his pose
at sensei, might
sit as apprentice
while Barry lectures
himself back to level.
A smart thing where
Cyber is concerned
because a salesman
with doubts is
like a prostitute with
inhibitions, only--
'Getting their names wrong.
That's how we speak
about our customers.'
He glares. 'By the way,
thanks for the assist.
Really tremendous.
Just sit there while I
get'-- even when he's angry,
cursing comes hard to
Barry-- 'screwed up the rear.
Big help.
Your problem, Henry,
if you want to know,
is you always think
discretion is the better part
of valor.' Nothing useful
could come of this.
When at last we part company,
I'm glad to be rid of him."
Thank you all.
AUDIENCE: It seems
like, recently, there
has been an uptake in the
number of books that are written
about people at work
who aren't detectives
or soldiers or something.
J. BRADFORD HIPPS: No vampires.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Right.
At their jobs.
Do you think that-- well,
do you think that there's
a particular reason for this?
And do you think it has
anything to do with the fact
that it seems like today,
it's harder than ever
to make a living
just as a writer,
so maybe more people are
working at regular jobs?
J. BRADFORD HIPPS: It
could be connected to both.
I don't-- you guys
probably have the data.
I don't have the data on
how many works of literature
actually now attempt to do
anything with what we would
commonly call the work world.
It still seems to be
pretty thin on the ground.
But by the same token,
I think the reality
is almost every writer you've
ever heard of had a day job.
You can probably
count on one hand
the number of writers that don't
have other means of income.
I think the
difference, of course,
is that, maybe traditionally,
those day jobs were academic.
I don't know how
many campus novels
we saw in the '50s and '60s.
And it may be simply
that, you're right,
that we're beginning to
transition out of that period
and that writers, probably for
the better for the work anyway,
are finding themselves with
more diverse and different
positions.
But the other thing
I will say is--
and maybe people are
waking up to this.
I don't know.
But I said elsewhere, and
this sounds like hyperbole.
But I mean it.
I think, after the battlefield,
the work environment
has the richest set of human
drama you're going to find.
And that's, I think, for
a variety of reasons.
But one of the big reasons
is, like a battlefield,
we're all thrust together.
We don't necessarily have much
say over who our coworkers are.
And that's going to lead to all
kinds of interesting things,
both positive and negative.
So I think it winds up
being an environment
rich in fictional possibilities,
if you see it that way.
This is a little bit my
slight soapbox remarks
about the satirical
view that people take.
That's such a failure of
imagination ultimately.
It's such a flattering way
to think about what we do.
I think if you don't
think about it that way.
The fictional possibilities
are everywhere.
That was a good question.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering if you
had like a favorite
quotation that you've ever
written in when you reread
it, you're like, wow,
that was really good?
J. BRADFORD HIPPS: Oh, that
I have personally written?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
J. BRADFORD HIPPS: Oh,
that's a great question.
Do I have a favorite quotation
that I've ever written?
I have hundreds.
No.
Let me-- I would have
to think about that.
There is one--
this is shameless.
People are going to think I
planted you in the audience
to ask that question.
There was one-- there's
one in this book.
I don't-- maybe I can find
it as I'm fumbling along.
Maybe I won't because I've
just put a lot of pressure
on myself, and it's got to
be something amazing given
the question you asked.
A broader answer is, yes,
there are certain phrases that
are in the book that stick
with me because I think,
as a writer-- I don't know
if other folks in them
are writers, but the condition
of a writer, generally,
is you spend most of your
days in agony with things
not working and looking
terrible and basically
thinking and feeling
like you're a fraud.
But from time to time, you
have a moment where you connect
to something, and it comes out.
And the words arrange
themselves the way
they need to be
arranged, and it speaks
to a sentiment or an
experience that you don't think
is commonly spoken to.
And when that happens,
it's just a little moment
of catching lightning
in a bottle.
And so, yes, there
are several of those.
Not lots and lots, but several.
Thank you for that question.
AUDIENCE: I don't know what
other people's experience
coming to work is,
but my own experience
is that the percentage of my
personality that comes out
in the work world
is rather small
relative to what could come
out in the rest of my life.
Was that challenging
for you to create fully
three dimensional
characters in this setting?
J. BRADFORD HIPPS: Maybe.
So one general observation
is-- I agree with you.
I think it sounds
like a negative thing.
But we almost have to live
these bifurcated existences.
And there's one mask
we're going to dawn when
we come into this space.
And it's-- that sounds terrible.
But the reality is we have
to get together and work
hard and go along to get
along even if we don't feel
like it or we've had a
horrendous night before
or whatever the case may be.
So I agree with that.
What is the possibility
that introduces,
I think, in this book and
particularly for the narrator,
is that that begins to exert
a particular pressure on him
because he has been a person,
like many of his coworkers,
who is pragmatic and
rational and levelheaded and
well-adjusted and--
but there is pressure
from his personal
life in this book
and a large part of the
book is what happens when
that pressure becomes greater
than maybe he can contain
in that work-oriented mindset.
But you're right.
I mean the flip
side is, if you're
going to set a book
in the work space
and you're not going to make
it a satirical one-- you
want to make
it largely realist--
you're right.
There are going to be
certain constraints.
You're not going to have people
going into operatic crying fits
or doing other things unless
you're presenting characters
that are mentally disturbed.
But I would say I--
maybe this is true.
Maybe it isn't.
I certainly can't make any
claims from my own writing.
But I think, even in scenes
like that short when we read,
there's clear tension
both on the surface
and below the surface that's
occurring even though people
are largely polite.
Keith has that one slight
outburst at the end.
But people are largely polite.
And I think it's
the fact that you
are trying to keep a lid on
that politeness, even when,
underneath, you may
feel anything but,
that by itself is
sufficient tension
to drive parts of the story.
But it is a good question.
You have certain
creative constraints
if you're going to
say it's a work story.
There are certain
ways people can behave
and certain ways
they can't behave.
That's a good question.
AUDIENCE: The
question I have is,
can you briefly describe
your creative process?
What sparked the idea?
And how do you build
out an outline?
Or how do you get to the
final product, I guess?
J. BRADFORD HIPPS: I don't
know if I can briefly
describe the creative process.
As I've mentioned, I was-- I had
been working for about 10 years
when I decided I
wanted to try to write.
So I had not-- I feel as
though a lot of writers
know out of the gates that
that's what they want to do.
And they start in their
teens or early 20s.
And they go heads down and--
so I was at least 10 years
delayed on that.
I would like to say
now productively
so because I think
that gives you time
not only to live
your life, but also
just to let certain
experiences build.
That's different from saying
you have any sort of wisdom.
But you've lived enough
things to know what happens.
And as I say, one of the
things that I was drawn to
was I was doing a lot of reading
as-- obviously, like all of us.
You work your day job, and then
you go home and do what you do.
And one of the big
things I did was read.
And as I said, I was
just struck by the fact
that there's just almost
no literature that actually
looks at the workplace.
So that was absolutely a trigger
point for thinking about it.
But to be a little bit more, I
guess, practical or pragmatic,
I also realized
at that time, even
if I had this
incohate idea, that it
was going to take a lot of
time to really try to do it.
And so I left my job,
and I went and got
a masters in fine
arts, which is really
just-- it's like apprenticing
yourself to other writers,
right?
I mean before the
MFA programs existed,
Hemingway had all
his crew in Paris.
And he could just
apprentice to them.
I think MFA programs today
are our apprentice programs.
And what you discover
in that process
is that you just don't know
what you don't know as somebody
who would be a writer.
And a huge part of that
is writing and developing
an allergy to what
you write and then
beginning to develop
the vocabulary
to understand why what
you write is so awful
and, again, beginning to
understand what it might look
like if it weren't so awful.
So there's no simple answer.
There was the idea.
It nagged at me enough.
It didn't go away.
It wasn't like I had this
idea for a couple weeks,
and then it just faded.
The idea sat there.
And then I finally
decided, well,
I need to do something
with this idea.
And that's where the practical,
pragmatic part of you kicks in.
What would it mean to go
do something with this?
Getting up in the mornings,
writing on the side
isn't enough because
I need people
who know what they're
doing to look at it.
So in my case, that meant
taking the subsequent steps.
We'll see what happens
in the next book.
AUDIENCE: Fresh on my mind is
your Op Ed about technology
and humanities being necessary
to advance both, I think,
certainly advance technology.
And I think we all
live insulated.
We live in this tech bubble.
We talk about it as
the tech bubble, right?
And one of the things I heard
from a different meeting
this morning was about the
Brexit and how a lot of people
are feeling left behind in
this new economy and maybe even
our culture.
Do you think
technology has a lot
to do with what's going on
politically in terms of people
feeling left out?
I mean I look at my parents.
And my dad wants
to sometimes throw
his phone against the wall.
He's like, I don't know
how to answer this thing.
Is that part of the problem?
J. BRADFORD HIPPS:
I am going to regret
saying I talked about anything.
Because you've now put
a Brexit question in it,
I'm going to be really stumped.
No.
Let me fumble my way
through because I
think if I were to go back
to-- the short answer is,
is technology-- is
it, if you will,
flattening things for folks?
Or is it actually
a distancing thing?
Is it making the elites higher
and everyone else left behind?
The short answer
is I don't know.
I can see an
argument either way.
But what I would say-- and
this was part of the reason
that I wound up writing
that particular Op Ed
piece is I guess
I-- I don't think
resent is too strong a word.
But I resist or resent the
idea that-- this push that
is on right now which is
to basically say, look, we
need to throw out the
humanities because it
has no vocational merit.
And we have to get all our
15, 16, and 17-year-olds just
to study engineering.
To me, it's misguided
for a couple reasons.
First of all, it
feels as though we're
trying to create some
sort of high priest class,
and the only way to
get into that class
is if you know what bits are.
But more broadly, my
feeling is that's just
a fundamental
misunderstanding of software.
And folks are-- obviously, feel
free to disagree with this.
But my assertion
is that software
is more creative as an activity
than it is algorithmic.
That's more or less the
point I was trying to make.
This notion that it's
all about the bit
heads, and it's just about
these engineering geeks.
That's just, I think,
fundamentally misguided.
It does not correspond
with my own experience.
The best developers
I've worked with--
and I'm a far cry
from these folks.
But the best developers
I've worked with
are fundamentally
creative souls.
And it was only coincidental
whether they'd actually been
born and bred in engineering.
They were philosophy
majors and music majors
and folks that had come out
of these artistic degrees.
So I realize that's a little
adjacent to the question
you're asking, which is,
is technology-- is it
making better or worse this
feeling that we're separating?
And I'm not-- as I said,
I'm not sure of the answer.
But the one thing I
do feel strongly about
is our desire to say there's
only one true path to become
effective in technology.
And if you're not
on that true path,
you might as well just-- I don't
know-- go open an apple cart.
To me, that just is
totally misguided
and doesn't make any sense.
And maybe if-- hey, if I'm
right and if people wake up
to that, then maybe fewer people
feel excluded and feel like,
well OK, this is
something I can tackle.
I mean, again, I don't
know if it's controversial.
But learning to program,
it's learning a language
fundamentally.
And lots of people are capable
of learning a language.
Now, obviously, the best
developers do more than that.
But this idea that it's this
thing for just very select few,
it doesn't feel right and
probably not good for us
on a macroeconomic level either.
AUDIENCE: There's a pretty good
size collection-- population
of writers at Google.
They have day jobs, of course.
They always ask this.
What's your advice?
J. BRADFORD HIPPS: Keep
your day job is my advice.
Yeah.
I think maybe I'll be
singing a different song
five years from now.
But I think-- unless
your job is-- I mean.
With at least this
cohort, I feel
comfortable saying
we're not coal miners.
We have it reasonably easy.
Not to say our jobs aren't
stressful, but-- and as long
as you feel as though the job
can be contained, if it's not
bleeding you dry and leaving
you with nothing left over
to do anything
else-- in which case,
you would probably be looking
regardless of whether you're
a writer or not.
But I think as long as
it can be contained,
then I think it can be
productive because, as I say,
it puts you into
encounter with folks
that you don't otherwise
necessarily choose
to be encounter with.
And some writer-- I can't
remember which one said this.
But he had this great phrase.
He said, "People come to you
dripping in mystery," which
I think is a great way,
maybe a subtly vampiric way
to look at people,
if you're a writer.
But it's true that
everyone comes
with his or her own story.
Everyone has genuinely
fascinating experiences.
And as a writer, you
want your radar up
and attuned to those
kinds of things.
It's what informs a lot
of what you're after.
At least, a lot of what
I'm after in a book, which
is to try to make
sense of my own life
and to try to see
existence as I've
lived it depicted in a
credible and real way.
And I think if
you-- I don't know
what the magic utopia
some writers think exist.
If it's to shut
yourself up in a tower
and never have to do
anything other than work,
I'm afraid, ultimately,
that's going to come through
in the writing itself.
It's going to start to feel very
hermetically sealed and sterile
and chilly, whatever other
adjective you might come up
with.
So that's my plug for
the value of having
to get up and work
something that
is not related to your writing.
As I say, give me
another five years,
I may be ground down to nothing.
And I'll give you a very
resentful, different answer.
But that's my answer right now.
Thank you all very much.
Really appreciate you coming.